extra special day here at the ramsay
show in ramsey headquarters
our good friends joshua milburn and ryan
nicodemus known as the minimalists
are visiting with us we love these guys
we love the work that they do and it is
so akin to teaching you people to live
on
less than you make a concept congress
can't grasp
so uh honored to have my friends here in
the studio guys thanks for joining us
hey we're honored to be here thanks for
having us dave we love you brother
you too man so uh the new dock is out
less
is now on netflix and it's a
huge hit i mean it's as always with you
guys
the only the only thing you had that
harmed it was you put me in it but um
and so all the dave haters now hate the
minimalist it's mandatory to
to cancel somebody for something but man
but anyway it's it's fabulous
it's very well produced i love the
scenes and uh your artistic touch as
always standing in front of the brick
walls and stuff and the anger camera
angles and
the reenactments of when you were
working and all that kind of stuff it's
very well done guys did you have fun on
it oh man
so much fun i wish i could say that we
had you know something to do with that
art piece of it but really
our director matt diavela he is a savant
so yeah the videography really um i got
to give it up to matt i got to give
credible credit stu but yeah we had a
lot of fun making it and
i'm really glad to see it uh uh going
across the tv screens all across the
world
yeah it's gone gone huge okay let's
backtrack because
there might be someone out there who
just emerged from a cave and never heard
who the minimalists are
and so we should uh upgrade uh their
knowledge and
catch them up to where the rest of us
are so minimalism
and the minimalists uh give me the
two-minute
version of what it is and how you got
here yeah so it really started with two
events in my life my mother died my
marriage ended both in the same month i
was 28 years old
sort of at the pinnacle of my corporate
career i was ostensibly successful had
all the trappings of the american dream
but for me that also meant a lot of debt
a lot of stress
a lot of anxiety and of course in our
world a lot of stuff
the average american household has 300
000 items in it
i had all of those things and more and
it's not there's anything inherently
wrong with the things the problem is
that i had so much stuff
that i was forsaking the people closest
to me
and i realized that all of my priorities
were out of whack i was
so focused on so-called success and
achievement and stuff
accumulating these things they weren't
making me happy they weren't doing their
job
and i realized i needed to simplify my
life and that's really where this thing
called minimalism
came in minimalism is just the thing
that gets us past the thing so we can
make room for life's most important
things
which aren't things at all that's not to
say that ryan and i are against
stuff the problem is we have so much
stuff that's actually getting in the way
of living a meaningful life
you know i mean we're like most of us in
america uh
we're just stuff obese i mean we just
have stuff coming out our ears
when you move and you have a box i
remember this when i was when i was a
kid when we were moving
you have a box that says seldom used
kitchen items
that might be a sign that you have too
much stuff
yeah sounds like another name for junk
drawer to me yeah yeah
in the kitchen junk drawer seldom used
kitsch
ronco apparently sold this crap i mean
you know i don't know but we
buy everything in sight and because
we're sold
everything in sight what did you call it
in the documentary uh you called it
stuff itis right tough ida
yeah i mean we unfortunately uh
we we look at these things as a shortcut
we look at uh
purchasing the new car going on the
vacation buying the bigger house i know
for me
when i got into minimalism it was
because i wanted to get my time back and
the reason why i didn't have control of
my time is because i had so much debt
and to pay all of those debt payments i
had to work a crazy
uh crazy job 60 70 sometimes 80 hours a
week
and every time i got a promotion i never
thought to myself oh here's an
opportunity for me to pay off debt it
was always an opportunity for me to buy
more more yeah because i was looking for
a shortcut to happiness i was looking
for a shortcut to status
a shortcut for um significance really in
in some ways
well and our messages have overlapped
for uh probably
close to a decade now uh where we just
say stuff like you know
it's okay to have a nice car it's just
not okay for a nice car to have you
that's exactly right
and you know it's the same kind of vibe
it's this whole thing no
it's stuff is not evil but when you
gorge
yourself on stuff you're you're going to
get satiated you're never satisfied yeah
it's called called the hedonic treadmill
right yeah we what we do is we
we get something and that becomes our
new baseline and so i went from the
toyota to the lexus and
so when i had a lexus i all of a sudden
i needed two lexuses lex
eye because
it was right there one was not enough in
our culture it's always more and more
and more and more we never stop to
consider
less and the only way to consider less
is to identify what is
enough in my life and it when we
identify we have enough
things what are we making room for well
we're making room for our values we're
making room for contribution we're
making room for our family and friends
the people in our lives
it's much more about that than it is
about amassing more things into our ever
busy lifestyles so less is more the old
maximum is where you came up with less
is now yeah because it's the it's so
cool to be now
and again when you want to read this is
not a thing to say you're spiritually
evil if you have stuff
no no it's nothing to say stuff is bad
at all no it's not the stuff's fault no
it's that we put it on a pedestal right
right absolutely
yeah i look at uh it's easy to do the
advertisements we see every day it's
over
5000 advertisements that's a lot of
noise it's a lot of
things seeping into our subconscious so
i mean the thing like minimalism really
helps us kind of
uh sift through all that noise and what
i really like about our documentary
lessons now
is it's really it's about starting over
it's about someone who is who is
stressed out by their stuff
stressed out by debt who really is
looking to make a shift in their life
uh we have uh well we're calling them
everyday minimalists in this documentary
uh everyday people who have been have
found a way to start over whether
they're single whether they have
families
and they've really been able to make
some major changes in their lives to to
live a more meaningful life
it's impossible to sit and watch the
thing
the documentary though and not just go
pause and go
god there's so much crap in this house
i'm sorry or you're welcome i don't know
it's just useless you know i mean it's
just useless
think about this dave we've been using
this word a lot lately essential
essential businesses essential travel
but now we're a lot of us have been
stuck at home for more than we
bargained and all of a sudden we're
looking around saying what is essential
in this house
yeah and i thought i was gonna need all
these things especially if i'm spending
more time at home but it turns out
i need it less than ever it's just
getting in the way
the documentary is less is now by the
mental
minimalists uh ryan nicodemus joshua
milburn are with us
and uh you guys be sure and check it out
on netflix we're gonna come back and
talk a little bit more about this but
this is uh
this idea of minimizing this idea of
simplifying it's catching on it's a bit
the minimalists have created a huge
movement around this
and and it gives you good pause uh
psychologically
to tap the brakes a little bit and just
go okay what matters
what is real i'm gonna be intentional
with his life spiritually godliness with
contentment
is great gain let's breathe a little bit
maybe if amazon didn't show up at your
front porch for a whole week life would
go on
thank you bra who knew
and gosh i mean you can whoo man i'm
telling you
wow all right we'll be back with these
guys for one more segment here in just a
second it's the minimalists
so 240 billion dollars is spent on
advertising today
that's a lot of money yeah and
when you think just about what is spent
on a given item
or we think about the power now of
amazon or the power
of uh facebook marketing or uh
the power of the data collection that
google has on individuals to custom
offer
you things that you just can't do
without because the offer is so
dialed in to exactly who you are right
yeah i mean you really
if you don't have a lot of intellectual
prowess you are almost
powerless to the sway that they put over
the top of you in this
and so we end up with just what we're
talking about is the minimalists are
about minimizing your life not stuff is
evil
not money is evil not you're a bad
person if you have a nice car
it's not that kind of stuff this is not
gnosticism it's minimalism
right and so but it is about make your
stuff have meaning
and when you've got so much stuff you've
just gorged on it it's just like all you
do is eat candy
and you've got no no nutrition in your
life your stuff is giving you no
nutrients yes
there's no happiness coming from it the
documentary is less is
now and with all this advertising money
spent we've all got to put our guards up
uh because otherwise we just get sucked
into this vortex of consumerism
materialism
and and lost so you guys have helped so
many people by giving them a guideline
giving them a rule or a step so what's
the first thing if you go yeah dave i
agree with what you're saying i agree
with what
joshua and ryan are saying but so what
do i do now because i got a house full
of crap
well we start the film with a question
how might your life be better with less
and the reason we asked that question
it starts with the why too instead of
the how to the how to sort of manifest
as soon as you understand the why and
that's what i love
with what you do with your work is
helping people understand the benefits
of getting becoming debt-free the same
thing is the benefits of simplifying
your life
understanding the why for some people
it's financial freedom sometimes
it's getting your time back sometimes
it's improving your relationships
sometimes just i want less stuff to
clean in my house my house is so full of
clutter
but also realizing that physical clutter
is just a physical manifestation of
what's going on inside this if you have
a bunch of material clutter
you have spiritual clutter mental
clutter emotional clutter
all of this internal clutter and it
starts with the stuff but as we start
decluttering
that stuff we're able to look inward we
also have some rules like we have 16
rules for living with less on our
website it's a free ebook people can
download
and i'll give you a couple of them here
one's the seasonality rule
we also call it the 90 90 rule if you
look at an item in your house
and say have i used this item in the
last 90 days
if not am i going to use it in the next
90 days if not i give myself permission
to let go
and that covers all seasons so right now
if i use it in the winter nope okay am i
going gonna use it in the spring
nope am i using the summer nope all
right let's get rid of it uh
we hold on to so many items just in case
another rule we have the just in case
rule
think about everything that's a hoarder
rule right right
that's the hoarder excuse for everything
i might need this
later yeah in some hypothetical future
that doesn't actually exist and so
anything that we're holding on to just
in case we can let go of because we can
replace it for less than 20
in less than 20 minutes think about this
though you never have to use the rule
once you get rid of it you don't miss
the thing
and you're able to move on as soon as
you like it's really cheap insurance and
it's definitely cheaper than you know
renting out a storage unit every single
month to keep all that just in case
stuff
that that adds up for sure yes it did
yeah the just in case
surcharge oh wow there's one more
tax on just in case yeah spontaneous
combustion rule so
if you have an item that's feeling a
little bit burdensome and you're
struggling i put so much meaning in it
of course if everything's precious
nothing is precious right
but if i'm putting so much meaning in
this but ask yourself how would i feel
if this item
spontaneously combusted right now how
would that make me feel
and if you'd feel a sense of relief
maybe it's time to let go
yeah yeah you know that does not mean
you can burn your house down
no okay another good place to start um i
think you mentioned uh
your daughter rachel had uh played this
game but the 30-day minimalism game or
the hashtag less is now challenge
it's a great great way to start because
it helps you get that momentum that you
need in order to start to decluttering
your life so the way it works is you
find a friend or a family member who
wants to get rid of some stuff and and
we know that decluttering can be a
little bit boring a little tedious
so this makes it fun because you bring
someone else in and then you make a bet
to see who can go uh the longest each
day of the month
getting rid of items so you start on day
one you get rid of one item then you go
to day two you get rid of two items and
then day three three items and then
okay so forth and so on you probably get
it uh whoever lasts the longest
wins if both people last the whole month
they both won because they would have
gotten rid of about 500 items each which
is a great start
yeah that's a lot of junk it is yeah but
and
you know watching the documentary it was
just like a thing of you know
scotch tape all right that's one thing
yeah or what i mean it doesn't have to
be like you
you sold your car right exactly exactly
and that could be a big item it can be
it can't be you know i guess you could
technically count like you know
12 paper clips on day 12. that's kind of
cheap
that's the box come on no cheating
yeah that's right that's for sure so
we're consumed
with spending this economy basically
exists on spending so
i mean stimulus oh stimulate things
yeah stimulate things and what this does
rachel talked about it over dinner one
night because rachel of our three kids
is the spender and she's obviously the
one that
is on the television on the radio show
does podcasts on best-selling books on
money which is irony of ironies but the
uh but rachel's
uh her she talked about it it was almost
like detoxing
yes you know it's a cleansing sense a
sense of
i just feel better yeah i'm complete in
an empty room
and so there's nothing wrong with the
stuff it enhances my life it augments my
life
but it's not me it's not part of my
identity unfortunately it has become
part of our identity
i am this thing and we even use terms
like i love
my truck or i love my house or i love
my bed there's nothing wrong with
enjoying things we get confused when
we love our truck but i also love my
wife
i love my daughter it's a little
different yeah
exactly a little different yeah the
documentary is less is
now it is on netflix both of the
documentaries are still on netflix as a
matter of fact you can go see the
original
and see the whole sequence that way if
you want to joshua milburn run nicodemus
are my guests
this half hour and um you know we want
people to take control their money we
want them to get out of debt
and how does minimalism fit into that i
mean that's really why i started um
i wanted to reclaim my time i was like i
said earlier i was working 60 70
sometimes
80 hours a week to pay all of these debt
payments
and uh yeah i saw minimalism as an
opportunity for me to simplify
for me to get rid of as much debt as
possible
and really i mean dave my original plan
was to go be a barista
i was gonna go serve coffee 20 30 hours
a week but in order to get
there i had to get rid of some stuff and
i had to get rid of some debt now uh the
minimalist was a beautiful accident 10
years later i still hope to be a barista
one day by the way
okay just haven't got there yet we got a
machine out here if you don't make it so
much people coffee
espresso machine all right yeah we let
you practice but but you know i really
just wanted to get my time back and
that's
that's what i think minimalism can help
anyone do anyone who is
dissatisfied with the status quo anyone
who wants
an opportunity to start over i think
minimalism is a way
that people can do that it's i don't i
don't want people to mistake it for
the way like we're not just saying
minimalism is but it's a way it's a tool
that people can use
in an area that we're just so
overwhelmed it's time to get a little
underwhelmed
i mean not minimalism hey new book
coming out you guys come back in july
when this comes out
love people use things be watching for
it
and probably learn about it at the
minimalist.com maybe a pre-purchase this
is an advanced reader copy i got
i'm not giving it back either love
people use things because the opposite
never works right amen we'll sign it for
you absolutely do it right now
thanks guys love you guys appreciate you
hanging out with us man thank you so
much